All right, what's up guys? Uh in this
video I'm going to go over how to use
kind of developing value, the basics of
it. I'm going to go over some settings
and show you kind of through the past
few days how you actually implement this
in your trading. So, for starters, the
actually the you know, the tool itself,
we have our own VWAP suite, so um
So, basically it's all VWAPs built into
one tool, different standard deviations.
Uh it's got previous period levels,
labels for all of the VWAPs, all rolling
VWAPs built in. Lots of different
styling and stuff like that, so uh
that's available as well under our
membership or as a standalone product if
you want to use that. Uh but ultimately
to to get these levels you can use any
VWAP you like, so
ultimately if you go up to indicators
here and search VWAP, uh TradingView has
their own technical, I mean there's lots
of other indicators as well.
Um so, once you have that loaded up,
I'll kind of go over my settings here.
It's going to look a little bit
different once you load it up being that
this is something that I've had made, it
it's different than the standard one,
but ultimately the levels and uh
everything is the same.
Uh so, in regards to developing value or
DDA,
or scalping VWAP, whatever you want to
call it, um you're going to be using
daily, right? Um
weekly up to yearly, those are
longer-term VWAPs, so that's a bit
different. Um and then ultimately your
standard deviation bands are how you
actually get these levels. So,
VWAP itself is the mean. That's that's
where, you know, throughout the session,
um
you know, that that that's where buyers
and sellers are happy to interact, let's
just say that. You know, it's kind of
it's fair price really, you know, so. Um
VWAP itself isn't always a trade
location, there's times when it is, but
ultimately um
better execution is found around the
standard deviations of VWAP, so um
>> [clears throat]
>> essentially VWAP is a is a dynamic value
area. So, this is the mean, this is
value area high, this is value area low.
This is standard deviation -2 and this
is standard deviation +2. So, to
actually get this set up for yourself,
what you'd want to do is for me, I like
I said, my settings are different, but
ultimately you'll have uh if you're
using the standard VWAP, for example, uh
you would have actually know what I'll
just pull it up here. Let's do it this
way.
Let's go like this and we'll set it up.
Right, so ultimately it probably won't
even look like this.
Oh, I guess it does. Okay, so ultimately
this is the regular view up on
TradingView. You can get started with
this.
Anchor period, this is you know what it
actually is. So if it's a weekly view
up, daily so and so forth.
Session is daily in this case. That's
just what TradingView calls it. So this
is what you want in regards to DVA.
Right? And then styling is obviously
whatever you want to put it as.
So this is where you actually get your
kind of dynamic developing value area to
trade throughout the day.
>> [clears throat]
>> So bands calculation you want standard
deviation because like I said, this the
idea of a value area whether profile or
view up is one standard deviation either
side of the mean. And the mean is the
point of control in regards to a profile
or it's the it's it's the view up in
regards or sorry, it's view up in
regards to uh
view up itself.
Right? So
bands multiplier one. So this is one
standard deviation from the mean. So if
you made this 1.5,
it'll be 1.5 standard deviations. Right?
So one is what you want to get your
actual value area. Right?
So that's what that is and if you want
the
standard deviation two, which is kind of
your you know, you'd call it your
rotational extreme, let's say. It's
standard deviation two.
Right?
When you get into coloring here,
I personally this is all preference, but
to me you can make it whatever you want.
So for example, I would make the view up
let's say like light gray or white.
Upper band, you can make this whatever
you want. I would probably keep it a
similar color, make it gray.
Something like that.
Upper band two, I would usually do about
the same.
And then my personal preference for the
way I like to do this, I don't fill this
one, but I do fill
the first standard deviation being that
that is your you know your value area.
So, I would uncheck that or sorry,
unclick that.
Um and that's how I'd go about doing
that. And you can make this whatever you
want. If you want to make this a bit
more gray, and then ultimately that's
kind of what you have there.
Now, when it comes to actually trading
it,
um
there there's a few different ways you
can do it. So, in regards to kind of a
scalping context,
you can trade just off of this. I mean,
you can get an idea uh of the kind of
moves you're going to be getting off of
this ultimately, right? So, um if you're
scalping intraday, this could certainly
be one of your you know your main tools
you're looking to trade, right? As well
as order flow and things like that, uh
which we cover all of this extremely
in-depth in our Discord, uh as well as
as using DVA specifically in all VWAPs,
but um anyway, I'll touch on the basics
of how you can use this. So,
uh it's going to be less usable at the
beginning of the day. So, for example,
like I said, these are daily VWAPs.
Um it's going to be less usable until
you know the bracket actually starts to
expand, right? And you get something to
work with. So, I mean, throughout here
this this is pretty much useless for the
the first 10 15 minutes.
Conversely down here, right? This just
goes
um
completely imbalanced up at this point.
So,
um when it comes to actually trading it,
you want kind of that period to actually
start and you have a bracket to work
with. Um
but ultimately when you're scalping,
like I said, this can form trades for
you. Uh if you're trading medium to
higher time frame, this can kind of aid
in your execution. It is one way you can
look at it. Uh but ultimately kind of
the uh
the characteristics uh of of trading
this, right? So, um if you look at you
know, a profile for example, right? If
if you're familiar with with volume
profile or TPO, I mean, like I said,
it's exactly the same thing. So, I got
actually we have another video on the
YouTube as well going over VWAP, but
this is value area high, this is value
area low, and this is your mean, which
is VWAP, right? So, this is the same
thing.
POC is the mean, so this is this.
This is this and this is this. Right?
So, value area low is support when
you're inside a value.
Value area high is resistance when
This is where
you know, buyers and sellers are happy
to interact being that you know, this is
fair price.
Um and conversely you you know, you can
flip that level. So, value area high
when you're inside a value is is
resistance like I said, it can become
support.
And and same thing with VAL, right? So,
that's the way you're going to trade
VWAP. Of course, a lot a lot more goes
into it, but
ultimately if you go take a look here,
right? Um
even just here, right? You know, we we
open.
Right? Here's your open ultimately we
whoops.
Let's go back to that.
>> [sighs]
>> Ultimately the day opens here, right?
And here's value area high, so like I
said, you know, not much to look at
here, but even again, if you wanted to
go super granular here and zoom in on
this, right? We open, we rotate down to
standard deviation two.
We accept into value, we trade up to the
other side, and then you can see value
area high is support until proven
otherwise, right?
Uh
once we get up here, we kind of start to
range. You can see that you know, the
trend is no longer as strong as it was
before. Ultimately get one more kind of
aggressive move up. We see a move back
into value, so at that point what was
support is now resistance, and you know,
we see the move through value. Of
course, it didn't quite get there, but
there was you know, there's still a
trade there ultimately.
Right? And then from there, you know,
VWAP is is really just kind of
rotational, so at that point this is
resistance, this is support, this more
often than not if you're inside a value
is not somewhere you want to be trading.
Um
becomes, you know, bullish against VWAP
again, so value area high is now
support. You get a move into standard
deviation two, and then ultimately
price, you know, breaks down and finds
support at VWAP.
And then at that point it hasn't really
found acceptance above, right? It's
really just again building out kind of a
broader range, so no strength has really
been established. So, if anything, you
would have wanted to see this hold, and
then you'd probably see the trend
establish again, and VWAP would would
start to trend up with you with price.
But, ultimately, it rotated back to
VWAP, which capped price again.
Which is one of the things that can stop
the move, you know, through value to the
other side. It is is a you know, a VWAP
rejection or POC rejection.
Um and then at that point, right, that
stops the move. You get back into this
kind of rhythm state, and ultimately,
this isn't strength here. As much as
this is now support, right, there
there's been no initiative. So,
disregarding VWAP here, right, there
there is no follow-through, right?
There's no continuous higher highs being
made.
At that point, it's it's really just
finding weakness, right? A range isn't,
you know, a range isn't strength at the
end of the day, right? So,
>> [snorts]
>> as much as it found support here,
ultimately, it failed.
You got a retest of value area high, so
support
flipped to resistance, and you see the
move through value, which ultimately
holds as support again.
And it actually pops back up to VWAP
once more. So, so that would have been a
potential as well, albeit, I would say
lower lower risk or lower probability.
Um and then sweeps the low, and then
ultimately, it rotates back up to
previous day VWAP at that point.
And then you can, you know, this this
cycle is really quite continuous. So,
right? Rotational move through value,
bullish against value, accepts back
inside VWAP.
Right? Accepts back inside.
Support's now resistance, move through
value. Right? Move through value.
Fails to go bullish.
Moves back into value, and then you can
see that
you know, value area high is now
support. We're now bullish against VWAP.
You can see kind of this messy retest
back inside. First target's VWAP, right?
Ultimately, there there's a there's a
bounce there, but then trades back down
the other side of value.
And then, you know, at that point, we're
just rotational on the lower half here.
So, VAL is support, but ultimately,
price is capping at VWAP, so it's
rotational on the lower half of value.
Right? So,
this is support until proven otherwise.
This is resistance until proven
otherwise.
Right? So, I mean, that's pretty much
it. Pretty much covered the basics of
how this works. Albeit if you want to
learn all of this and and our entire
system and extreme kind of comprehensive
course,
that is available through our Discord.
Should you have any questions, don't
hesitate to reach out and yeah guys,
good luck with your trading and have a
good one. Cheers.